une écharpe remise par son conseil
municipal pour la troisième fois en mai
dernier bertrand au lion est réélu au
poste de maire de magny les hameaux
un siège qu'il occupe depuis 2012 à
l'âge de 36 ans et la démission de
jacques neau viol ça a été une
proposition qui m'a été faite il y
réfléchit on a discuté aussi ensuite
avec l'ensemble de l'équipe il y avait
aussi d'autres choix qui était possible
finalement bon bah il y a eu un
rassemblement autour de mon nom pour
pour mener les choses et être mère après
ça reste un travail d'équipé
je compare toujours une fonction de
maire à une fonction bénévole on se met
à disposition des autres élus
communautaires depuis 2000 16b
retrouvions et depuis ce mois de juillet
vice-présidente saint quentin en
yvelines en charge des espaces verts et
de l'agriculture une délégation à
l'image de sa commune magny les hameaux
porte une double identité urbaine et
rurale
on a toujours cette image en effet très
rural écoutez c'est la caractéristique
du territoire c'est c'est un atout pour
le bien vivre sur notre territoire
c'est un atout parce que c'est aussi à
échelle humaine on dit souvent magny les
hameaux et un peu particulier où on n'y
fait pas forcément les mêmes choses ou
de la même façon qu ailleurs c'est pas
grave
c'est peut-être exemplaire justement de
réussir à maintenir cette multipolarité
à l'intérieur d'une agglomération qui a
souvent été vu comme un mastodonte s'il
est engagé politiquement depuis 17 ans
pour la commune bertrand au lion a
choisi de garder un pied dans le monde
professionnel
entré en 1999 à la fédération française
de cyclotourisme
il en est aujourd'hui le directeur de la
communication passionné de vélo depuis
longtemps j'en ai fait mon métier tout
simplement
alors c'est une chance parce que et
c'est ce que je souhaite d'ailleurs à
tout le monde de réussir à avoir un
métier qui me plaît
pour moi c'est important parce que c'est
bluffant c'est la vie tous les jours
c'est à dire que mr c'est pas un métier
c'est une fonction sur un moment un
parti aussi dans la vie on sera pas mais
ravis on n'est pas élu à vie en ce qu'il
ne faut pas et la vraie vie c'est c'est
d'avoir son métier d'avoir son activité
professionnelle engagement associatif
jusqu'en 2001 président du conseil
municipal des jeunes de 1990 à 1993 son
mandat de maire prendra fin en 2026